hey I'm Joe Weisenthal co-host of what
you miss so obviously this week is fed
week everybody is wondering whether the
Fed will raise interest rates on
Thursday but one of the big problems is
that the Fed wants to see inflation
higher and it's not moving higher and
today we sell more of that this morning
we got the Empire fed manufacturing
index it's a survey of companies in the
new york region that see how they're
doing and one of the things they ask
them about is prices and they ask them
about how much they paid for raw
materials and how much they're getting
for the goods that they sell and that's
these two lines and both of them are
heading down as you can see the prices
that companies are paying for goods
obviously heading down you know because
commodities and oil and all that stuff
and then this yellow line is the prices
that they're getting when they sell
their goods and they're also heading
down so this is the feds the one thing
the Fed can't do it wants to see prices
higher wants to see evidence of
inflation of tightness in the market but
everywhere we look we see the opposite
that there's just no inflation pressure
everywhere in fact prices are falling
and not rising and that's my color chart
much what do you miss it for PM eastern
you